I have a privilege
to introduce my good friend colleague
distinguished diplomat an organ or soul
with episodic Iceland to the United
Nations and currently during this
session he's sharing the Fed Committee
in the United Nations family this very
rare one
ambassador so easily takes to this chair
very dangerous to protect human rights
that's why if there is a choice
well the messages they're trying to to
take some something more easy like
disarmament for example or even fifth
committee budget or six Familia so I did
six committees so it's very curious to
take this this post but for a pastor
Gunnar solids
it's not something you his country's
leader in human rights protection that's
why for him it's easy to understand the
the main tendencies flows and
contradictions so today we will speak
about contradiction as well all these
difficulties between the universality of
Human Rights and particularity diversity
and how it works what doesn't work in
the United Nations system it's very
interesting some of the students here
they were the following your presidency
there we applauded in many in many
occasions so that's why welcome to your
family and please start and then we will
ask you well thank you Pastor - sir Kiev
because once an ambassador always an
ambassador for you never get rid of your
past in in the in this Bistro
first of all I'm honored to be here with
you at the L the McMillion Center for
International and area studies I am here
of course in my capacity as a department
representative of Iceland however I just
want to make the usual disclaimer that
today I will be speaking in my personal
capacity and not formally representing
the third Committee of the the General
Assembly of the United Nations normal
command the government of Iceland but of
course I'm speaking from the experiences
that I have from patrols but just want
to make this usual disclaimer about not
painting anyway any anybody else and
myself for what I'm going to and say
here the opinions and and use are mine
and mine only and and all the errors I
will make and I'm sure I will make a few
because I'm certainly not an expert that
is the life of a the offer of a diplomat
we can rarely be experts on the things
that we working on we rather generalists
dealing with these things so the errors
that I will make certainly make they
will all be the sole responsibility of
mine and I trust that all of you will be
happy more than happy to correct me
whenever I put my foot wrong during was
during this time that I have you have
this habit you here this afternoon
now as circular said Iceland had the
pleasure of the chairing the third
Committee of the General Assembly of the
UN this fall in the 72nd session it's a
year-long responsibility lasting from
September and initiate and September
next year and it's only the second time
that Iceland has undertaken this
responsibility of tearing one of the
main committees of the of the UN General
Assembly and the last time we did so was
more than 50 years ago
I'm correct however the work of the
third committee is concentrated on eight
weeks from from beginning of October
until Thanksgiving every year so I will
even though I will continue to serve as
a chair of the committee it is unlikely
that I will see many more meetings
outside now after after Thanksgiving the
third committee is indeed a very
interesting committee it was initially
the committee dealing with human rights
it was the party within the within the
international system or the human family
dealing with human rights and from the
beginning we had the third community of
the General Assembly and and we
Commission on Human Rights and just to
put this into perspective if I'm if I'm
correct actually the 1948 Universal
Declaration of Human Rights was actually
tested through the third committee
adopted there and and from there set on
to the General Assembly for proper
adoption today the third committee is a
part of a much larger system of Human
Rights mechanisms from the Human Rights
Council in Geneva with its Universal
Periodic Review or the UPR the and it's
a special mandate holders we can also
name the regional conventions and
commissions the human rights treaty
party system and of course there is
other fora that are dealing with with
with Human Rights
the third committee is served by a
standing Secretariat in the office of
the High Commissioner for Human Rights
a valuable support to the work that one
has and as I was as I was sitting at the
podium in October and November I for
most of the meetings I had the very
positive security feeling of having a
representative from the office of the
High Commissioner for Human Rights
sitting at my right hand side and
throughout most of the proceedings the
third committee has borne let's say
particular particularity within all of
these parties I was referring to and
that is that it is the only form that
has universal membership discussing
human rights humanitarian and social
issues and it may that makes it a very
important norms that embody and and in
that sense we can draw a distinction
between the third committee and most
other parties that are dealing with
human rights one could probably say that
the third committee should be sort of
the party that would be contemplating
new ideas preparatory work for any kind
of new Human Rights conventions or or
establishing new norms while it might
also be sensible at least to a simple
rider like myself to see many of the
other part is more concerned with the
operative part of the system cleanliness
is imported in for example in the UPR
processes of the Human Rights Council
now there is an overlap we see the third
committee starting to deal in with
specific situation as I will address a
little bit further more further on and
also we can see other bodies venturing
into the normative side of things not
dealing with specific situation but
rather addressing in more general terms
the norms that should apply however when
that happens on the normative site in
other bodies then we have this lack of
universal membership so I think this is
maybe the one of the most important sort
of sites to draw your attention to the
universal membership of the third
committee and it can also be an
explanation why we still meet the third
committee after we have the Human Rights
Council established and years ago there
is this fundamental difference between
the composition of the Human Rights
Council and that of the third committee
now during this session we saw the same
12
I can't items about allocated to the
third committee as usually concerning a
wide range of social humanitarian and
human rights issues we also saw a record
number of special mandate holders
interacting with the committee and over
60 resolutions that were adopted in the
in the committee and basically you can
divide the work of the third committee
two into three categories we deal with
this special with special mandate
holders through these interactive
dialogues and basically they are
organized in such a manner that we set
one hour for its interactive dialogue
they take place under a Monday that is
usually provided for by the Human Rights
Council it is a special report or on
this web issue that is working in the
scanner capacity and is mandated to
report back to the General Assembly
which is done through the third
committee and to the humorous concert
there are little bit of ress but this
would be sort of the general description
and we set aside one hour for it so it's
of this special mantle touch they come
in they make an introduction the member
states will then have the possibility to
make comments or post questions to them
and and the Special Rapporteur he or she
they will be given the possibility
towards the end to respond to the
questions and comments made we scheduled
three of them and in one meeting start
with last three hours and so it should
come as no surprise that this can be
quite challenging to provide for
substance that this discussion with 193
member states and one special month
adult within one hour especially as we
don't know at the outset how many we
have so we have to run a very strict
protocol without Ematic cut-off of
microphones and not just metal speaking
times we are Tessa pate at the beginning
that we would be able to give every
country that would want to pose a
question or make a comment three minutes
to do so but given the reality of of the
clock and when we see how many requests
we have for this war we sometimes have
to revert to cutting down these times to
down to us as little as one minute
elevation and so this is takes a bribe
the considerable part of the
time at the beginning maybe I would say
that this along with the general
discussions was referred to a little bit
afterwards they take up 2/3 of the time
the general discussions are organized so
that we close to this 12
I can't items into 70 beds and involves
debates they are topical and then in
member states can make interventional
statements and on these topics and the
third category and the work is the
resolutions and they come towards the
end of this eight weeks 60 64 I think we
64 how we have this year and they are
again topical dealing with many of the
same issues as before now I and of
course at the end the resolutions that
the committee is adopting they are
either adopted by consensus about
two-thirds of of them of this 60 a
little bit more than 60 resolutions are
adopted by consensus and the rest is
voted upon
just to give you a little bit of a
flavor of what we are dealing with I
would just like to mention a couple of
examples
[Music]
one of the first I can't items the
Social Development I we had this year to
interesting topics one on dealing with
the family resolution on the family and
another one on aging and the family
resolution after having not been up
after having not been submitted for last
year it was submitted I came up and by
the group of 77
and sometimes these resolutions over the
debates about them they can start to
revolve about the reminder things to the
untrained eye sometimes revolve around
commas or words and when it comes to the
family resolution it can even start to
revolve around a tense of world or would
anyone in this in this group be able to
explain why one group of countries would
prefer to say the family while another
group would insist on saying families
employers at the moment we have a little
bit of truth on this topic being able to
agree upon a neutral language avoiding
this term or family and we have seen a
similar process at the commission of
status of women where we have had a
class between some teleca's who's
proposing some very traditional some
would even say conservative language on
the family while other others have
wanted to call with a much more let's
say progressive wording and this of
course if the would be and if the route
animal be anyone in this room that and
it's not seeing what it is all about
it's about whether we are only talking
about the traditional nucleus a nucleus
family of a man and a wife and with some
children or or rather recognizing that
there are diverse composition of
families around the world and in
different societies
the other resolution I mentioned the one
on 18 RT Tina
is the one who has to lead there and
they are trying to build a consensus for
huge future action on addressing the
human rights of older persons whether
that might be through a treaty or an
optional protocol
despite questions from other delegations
if more treaties are needed
both of these resolutions were adopted
by consensus this year but I think this
is the good it's a good opportunity to
point out to the nature of the work of
the third committee and the General
Assembly in in in general and that is
that the resolutions that have been
adopted by the General Assembly they are
not panting they are not treaties they
are not the day to not impose
applications upon member states in the
same ways as when we are negotiating
with collateral treaties however at the
same time they are often precursors to
such treaty making later on and this
also means that the one could say that
resolutions of the General Assembly are
only as important as they are and
meaning that if they are generally
recognized they can actually have a
quite a strong effect on member states
and on general thinking about what is
what is accepted or preferable if they
are on the other hand highly contested
they that value might be diminished but
could still be important in
let's say fighting for a new course or
or defending some kind of an idea or
principles that people are working on
but in that sense then it because many
of them are recurrent then starts to
matter a lot well you see increased
support or decreased support from one
year to another enter the I can't I'd
ammonia transmittal women we had the
only one text that was the text of the
committee itself except they submitted
by me in my capacity as it's here on the
follow-up to the Beijing platform for
action on Kantor equality and as usually
this was adopted by consensus but one
little element that was acted there was
a strong warning to him reinforce the
support of mental states to the
secretary-general on his counterparty
club and I just mentioned this to draw
your attention to the effect of these
resolutions they may not only relate to
member states or what what is happening
in Memphis days they can also relate to
the interplay between the Member States
and the UN system or the Secretariat
what to do how to do it and on this
particular one one could question what
came first was at the base of the
secretary-general to to get support for
from member states on his plan on
counter parity in higher positions in
the within the u.s. system or or asset
is the driving force a wish from a man
possessed will post on the
secretary-general some discipline and in
this respect this year probably the most
challenging item was on the Rights of
the Child
with the two tax on the culture and the
rights of this health in some of the
last to be adopted with the tropical
violence against children causing quite
a controversy questions relating to
corporal punishment and the role of
parents were key topics and with the
issue of sex education being the course
of multiple amendment proposals and
finally I would say that a significant
part of the work of the committee was
held until at the nth item of promotion
protection of human rights where a
majority of proposals including the
so-called
country specific resolutions were
discussed now these country specific or
country specifics as we call them are a
very interesting component of the work
of the third committee as they relate to
the situation of human rights in
specific countries while the other texts
are related more to the specific themes
and trends and there again I come to
what mentioned earlier this sort of
blurred line between the normative side
of the law of the role of the third
committee and the more operative site
for example of the Human Rights Council
there we can clearly see that the third
committee is actually developing more
into into sort the particular situation
less on the normative side and trying to
influence what is happening on the
ground in a particular country the
relevance and role of this country
specific resolution is hotly debated as
the resolution themselves now we have
say two S's in Syria Iran and Crimea
being discussed and I would say quite
many saying that these resolutions are
in fact in
are an import important part of our work
to advance human rights in countries
where we are dealing with some of the
worst situations but then again we
should not forget you know that the
Human Rights Council is dealing with
this every day and and and they are
dealing with vastly more situations we
had this year again also a text on
Myanmar after it had been dropped for
the last session now it was introduced
by the Organization of Islamic States
coming together to submit attacks to
respond to the raw Inca crisis this text
would it could be claimed that on its
own it might not have carried much
weight but when it is seen as a part of
efforts by many others both individual
states and the rest of the UN system
I have heard quite strong testimony from
people working on the ground in Myanmar
where they claim these to have a
significant impact on the ground and
helping those that are trying to work on
the ground in order to improve situation
they're helping them a lot but the most
important question when it comes to
these is how two countries get selected
for country specific resolutions in
particular in the third committee why do
we not have a resolution on Iceland or
Saudi Arabia or the host country the
United States United States it is
clearly so when we look at the debate on
this country specific resolutions and
the interactive dialogues on the
uncounted specific cities in the inner
circle committee
that there is a sizeable majority of
member states that is of the opinion
that they are an important tool to try
to have positive effect on humor I see
two issues in these particular countries
or regions however and I would I would
say there's a this is a very sizeable
majority however made a little bit
silent one there is also a considerable
number of mental states clearly a
minority but a considerable minority
nevertheless which is very vocal about
their questions about the motivation
behind these country specific
resolutions and procedures believing
that they are quite politicized and are
being used for political purposes in in
in in a manner tatis can be from their
perspective seen as arbitrary by this
country or not that country is being
subjected to this process so when we are
working on these issues we also have the
tendency to see strong emotions
delegates sometimes can get quite
emotional we see a lot of we see a lot
of delegates reverting to using their
possibilities under the rules of
considers to either make replies to
comments made by all the delegations or
or complain about the management of the
of the of the meeting in a chair under
this concept in this situation means
that you have to be awake for the whole
tournament and be ready to deal with a
whether you are conducting the meeting
in right and proper manner it's
extremely important during these kinds
of debates to keep order to be non
partial partial to make sure that those
countries that are being put on the spot
they are treated with respect because
the first thing that goes out of the
window if you lose that is the substance
there's a flare in a meeting like this
and people start shouting at each other
as has happened the first thing that
will software will be the important
substance master tablet element which is
humorous of people on the ground so it's
always important to be able to keep
control
I would also like to mention one more
text
it was the text submitted man our way on
human rights defenders it's a tradition
of text on the important role of
individuals at work on the ground for
human rights it has been adopted
regularly at the UN with consensus for
several for a long time but last last
time it came up two years ago it
actually was voted on and we saw in my
opinion very welcome reversal that their
delegations were actually able to come
again to a consensus on this text and
avoid having it what Interpol and the
reason I say this is welcome is that
when you are working on issues like we
are working with Inter committee we
absolutely actually have to think about
consensus and why we are so preoccupied
with with consensus when we are working
at the UN now it is clearly saw that it
is the right of any member state to call
for a vote on whatever resolution they
want and nobody should cast him that
right and sometimes it may be important
as sometimes you might want to do it but
when we are dealing with soft law when
we are dealing with something that has
as I said as much effect as it has then
consensus can become the most important
tools that you have in order to advance
whatever you are trying to advance or in
order to fight against whatever you are
fighting against because consensus is
hard and what in this easy it's very
easy if you disagree with something just
to say I'm going to call for a vote
when you are working with the consensus
you are trying to influence people into
some kind of a an agreement on the
middle and when you do that it it can
very easily be claimed that you are
selling out you're selling out or
whatever idea or cause that you are that
you have close to your heart that you're
trying to advance or defend but the
reality is that when you don't have a
pending outcome the value of the outcome
is only as much as those that walk away
from the outcome given to it so when you
are negotiating in the UN on a consensus
you have you some concept to give
something but what you can gain is a is
a result that will actually enjoy wide
recognition as being something that
everybody should adhere to and that is
the reason that consensus is one of the
most important tools that we have this
year we saw one pick member state Larry
Bittman to state reverting to calling
for volts on several more items and
usually and as I said earlier it is
absolutely clearly the right of any
member state to do so but when you see
the results of these words coming out
maybe so that the one who called for
what is absolutely isolated being alone
maybe against the rest of the member
state membership then you can start to
at least want report
why you do that and I'm not saying that
the cannot be good justification to it
there may very well be some time
sometimes principle less of of paramount
importance and you should actually stick
to the principles but if you are trying
to use this process to influence always
to do something that you want them to do
or not to do something you don't want
them to do then it can't be questioned
how much value there is in calling for a
vote and then ended up being in either
alone or in a very very small minority
of those that have the same you as you
finally I would like to address a little
bit another interesting development that
we have seen in the last few years which
is stronger engagement by China it was
in the past it has been claimed that
China was not very vocal in the work of
the third committee for example we have
seen some changes to this for the two
years ago we saw them requesting a world
for the first time in our knowledge in
the third committee and last summer they
presented the first resolution in the
humorous Council on development in human
rights and you have certainly heard
claims that the Chinese approach may be
somewhat of a hierarchy of rights
emphasis on development and economic and
social rights such as right to food and
water housing etc and
there are some that are skeptical to
this approach
I have heard some classifying this as
being a promotion of an alternative to
the universality of human rights
others have used the words human rights
with a Chinese touch and it very much
touches upon this conversation about
whether human rights are truly universal
or if they are dependent on the
country's situation now I'm not going to
give any kind of final sort of answer to
all these issues I must only say that
from my perspective having been sitting
up at the podium sharing in thir
committee I actually believe that it is
very important to receive strong
engagement from the member state of the
of the UN in terms of number of people
and a country that everyone believes
will be ever more influential in the
multilateral fora
and in this sanctuary that we have just
started and I think actually we should
not see that as any kind of
in tux well incitement to any kind of
complacency when it comes to things that
we hold there like universal
universality of human rights but we have
to be able to engage with those that
might have different approaches that we
have and they see if we fear that that
they might be promoting something that
we do not agree with we simply have to
work harder on our argumentation for
what we believe in so just again from
the perspective of opine you know in the
chair of the third committee I
absolutely believe in the importance of
everybody participating and not only
those that may share exactly the same
approach or same views on things so in
that sense I find it highly welcoming
but it clearly poses some challenges
when you have more interactions more
stronger views and what we are dealing
with coming from new uncle shows
different uncle's than before and of
course it will request a lot from from
everybody participating list however in
in that I also say as US diplomat how
important I believe it is that we take
time to try to understand where people
are coming from and I think this most
important trend to an to understand
those that we disagree with it's it's
not so difficult with you know my
closest neighbor you know I come from
Iceland it's not so important that I
understand my friends from Scandinavia
you know we know listen sweets and they
you know Denmark Finland pattern and
understand them pretty well the further
away people are the more different of
opinions they have the more important it
is to understand them and understanding
does not mean agreeing so there's a
fundamental difference between those two
things and I sometimes wonder whether
whether people are tuned enough in terms
of trying to understand so the question
might be then candy you and efficiently
protect human rights and for me that
question goes back to the fundamental
question what the UN is the UN is not an
immaculate conception it is made by us
for us and as Hamas called the second
secretary-general of the United Nations
once said do we refer to the purposes of
the Charter they are expressions of
universally shared ideals which cannot
fail us though we allows
often fail them or do we think of the
institutions of the United Nations there
are our tools we fasten them we use them
it is our responsibility to remedy any
flaws there may be in them this is a
difficult lesson for both idealists and
realists though for different reasons I
suppose that just as the first
temptation of the realist is the
illusion of cynicism so the first
temptation of the idealist is the
illusion of utopia and I think tyranno's
called said this talking to the
International Association at McGill
University and
19:56 and i believe that it is therefore
upon all of us through our governments
to protect human rights and that without
us the UN cannot be expected to too much
so with this I would hope that you would
take charts and made me suffer and and
try to find out my weak spots for
example finding out that interes at the
reported podium for this eight weeks and
had going through my table probably some
thousands of pages of reports and
resolutions and other stuff I hope that
you will well not as we read all over
but over to you thank you Miss Anderson
thank you for very informative
comprehensive sharing what you did what
the third committee is doing what the
United Nations is doing so you mentioned
several countries specific resolution
some of them they they're coming back to
that committee committee annually so
it's predictable any kind of discussions
even we know who is going to use the
right to reply before the meeting starts
the people they don't like this kind of
resolution they do not like to mention
any problems of the member states that's
why they are fighting to have general
these specific resolutions in the Ted
committee
Domanick that we have the periodic
reviews in the Human Rights Council in
Geneva why we are bringing these issues
so and all this these meetings around
these resolutions are very tough tough
language ping-pong Inc and so on and
this why I was positively surprised when
at the last meeting you had the Syrian
representative thank you very much for
for your kind generosity and good
management of this particular issues it
never happened in my time of being there
so you did job well if they are
satisfied is that but the reality is
that next year we are going to celebrate
the 70th anniversary of universal human
rights declaration and this not only
this document but the the charter united
educators is being questioned
declaration is declaration and people
they are interpreting the provisions in
the way they want to interpret it you
mentioned one of the country who
selectively approaches to the
understanding of human rights taking
only economic or social aspect of the
rights when the human rights are
universal indivisible and there is an
integrity some of the countries with the
specific resolutions they are claiming
that look we are finding we are blind
blaming us because of violation of the
rights of assembly but we are so great
in protection of rights to health rights
to education so this is exactly about
the integrity of human rights
indivisibility so and if the problem is
revealed it doesn't mean a blame so
interpretation of the of the basic
documents United Nations is very
important for me it's interesting how
you conducted the Dominican for example
self-determination of Nations because
and particularly in the year when we
have a lot of the challenges in
Catalonia well in in Mali and anywhere
the my reading was what happened for
example in Crimea when
the rights of the russian-speaking
population was announced as the legal
base for for intervention to protect
that reason this manipulation of the
main one of the major provisions of the
Charter challenging other provision
territorial integrity interesting how
people would this year discussed this
illusion of self-determination this is
one of my questions of course what I
have been observing since 2007 when I
appeared so the conflict between the the
right to a choice and the right to
protect traditions transitions and
liberalism conflicting around many
issues in the United Nations including
third committee well so my my major
question is that we need preparing for
the 70th anniversary of human rights
declaration we need to speak more about
our responsibility of reading the basic
documents which are being read by some
of the countries voluntarily and using
worries today is useful politically for
them or for their interest yes you
clearly hit that bond on one of the very
important underlying issues I mean one
could clearly feel when dealing with
these issues this year around there are
a lot of questions coming up we of
course see the situation in Crimea where
majority of of member states clearly see
it as a territorial question and clearly
see Crimea's as being under occupation
or not having haven't been taken from
under the control of the rightful
authorities and at the same time we see
what is happening in Catalonia we see
the current discussions between the UK
and the European Union coming almost to
a a standoff over the issue of Northern
Ireland and looming in the background is
the issue of of geography TG posture and
we see intimately in Middle East we see
we see the issue of the Kurds and
covering several countries that we could
see regular flare-up of motions in the
committee between Armenia and Azerbaijan
so I think you have clearly pointed out
to one of the most challenging and the
questions and it's challenging because
for a long time it was mapping approach
rather easily with a very strong focus
from one direction which says which was
the question about self-determination
and sort of the height was flowing into
the same direction now we see that these
types of questions can come up in maybe
much more complex setting that that we
were thinking about in the last 60 to 70
years so
I certainly believe that this will be
very strong on the account in the coming
years and I don't think we have we have
seen the last of it in terms of country
specifics it's also worth to mention you
know that because I was referring to the
sensitivity of those countries that are
being subject to this country specific
resolutions but of course when we talk
about Crimea Ukraine it is Ukraine that
is actually bringing forward the the
resolution so it doesn't it does not
necessarily have to be in this one-sided
reality that you have a country that
feels it being subjected to some kind of
new pressure by the outside world it can
also be the other way around when one
country decides to use these venues to
take their particular issues and and I
also think when we look at these debates
I try to put at it before you have to be
ready to look a little bit under the
surface when we look at the country
specific dialogues whether it was on the
resolutions or in the interactive
dialogues if you would only listen to
what is being said you would probably
come to the conclusion that the
overwhelming majority of the member
states were extremely much against this
and that is what I was referring to when
I was talking about the silent majority
the clearly the majority is of the of
the opinion that these resolutions these
dialogues can be important and powerful
tools to improve the situation on the
ground to try to affect behavior of
certain member states maybe the
concerned member state or some other
member states that and have particular
stake but nevertheless I also believe
that we have to
ask ourselves as member-states why are
we doing things what is our objective
because we can have different objectives
sometimes we do things because it's good
for us back at home sometimes we do
things because we believe it has some
particular effect within a particular
country I must say sitting at the podium
and listening to those countries that
were very vocal about their objections
to these types of procedures I could not
really hear from them that they were
sending out any signals that they were
going to change their opinion or
behavior but I heard one thing they were
all very strong in proclaiming their
affection for the UPR of the Human
Rights Council and I'm I'm not
absolutely sure that they would all be
so happy about the UPR of the humorous
counsel if they would not have been
dealing with that but it's just a theory
of man yeah many many many many many
interesting developments when you are
looking who is the main reporters no
co-sponsor of some country specific
resolution for example Syria for you to
be interesting who brought this
resolution on the violation human rights
in Syria Saudi Arabia very interesting
so they are world is changing as well
despite the fact that Arab world
invented the parallel declaration
so-called Cairo declaration well so but
well there are some some developments
and I agreed that even even this this
kind of the dialogue and the process
very important when people they are
understanding the universal human rights
more and more in different regions but
the true is that the United Nations was
invented to protect and to defend people
and people's human rights
but we can't stop the perpetrators we
can't we are detecting problems
you are telling broadly but what is
going on Myanmar
so they are rejecting any an equation
starting the time they are terrorists
always almost 600,000 people they are
terrorists and so it can't stop them
that is that is why I don't know if it
exists this group or not but in my time
it was a group of ambassadors led by the
Liechtenstein ambassador demanding the
same mechanism of sanctions for the
Human Rights Council in Geneva as the
Security Council has in New York but
hardly d p5 in New York are ready to
share this mechanism so it means that
there is no mechanism how to stop the
perpetrators from the very beginning
then you don't have exact mechanisms
except the special tribunals like for
Yugoslavia and so on well to bring the
perpetrators to justice the only body is
ICC but it is not Universal mechanism
it's yeah it's true so some African
countries the the the hate ICC when it
is about the violation of human rights
in in their countries so it is true it
is one of the biggest gap in the United
Nations system that there is no
efficient mechanism how to stop the
perpetrators at the beginning well if
you want joint discussion with your
question so of course the the
universality and diversity it's very
important question a question I the
universality versus diversion or
diversion versus universality what we
are to speak more in the United Nations
about what is uniting us or to
understand our differences and then well
to find to find a better language so
I wen constant human I mean one thing is
you know the rights system and and and
what countries can agree on and cannot
agree on when it comes to the
implementation mechanism and we come to
the come to the Security Council I mean
the Security Council is the only body
that is empowered to use force against
sovereign countries and that force can
be in the form of military actions or it
can be in the form of of softer actions
like you know trade measures and and and
sanctions and and and stuff like that
and we just live by this simple reality
that there are five countries on the
Security Council that he'll veto powers
we can we can have a lot of issue with
that fact but it is a fact and it could
probably be argued that it was unlikely
that the Security Council would exist
without that fact and it would probably
never help inform without that fact but
it but it reflects the realities from 70
years Park not realities of today I
actually think that there is a very
strong agreement on on on many aspects
of human rights
and maybe I would even say most sort of
detainer lustres I mean there is very
little disagreement only only only on
the right to life what we see is very
very first two points of departure when
it comes to the interplay because many
human rights actually can affect some
other human rights I mean this classical
question I mean Fe Fe if we if we look
at if you look at well freedom of
expression I mean it's a classic thing
freedom of expression can class with
several other human rights and they have
to find some country balance so this
disagreement between countries is often
on on sort of this kind of balance we do
not or I do not detect many countries I
would say that would have fundamental
questions about broad specters or broad
spectrum of the of the human rights
shots but rather sort of on how to
approach them how to apply them having
said that I represent a country that
believes very strongly in universality
and intelligibility of human rights and
we have to take this discussion with
anyone that wants to have that
discussion and and and sort of try to
undermine the values that we are
are are fighting for and defending but I
don't think it is helpful when we are
doing that to sort of assumes that they
have some very alien motives that's my
point
I mean of course the United Nations has
instruments both legal and operational
but the question is that the intervenors
sometimes badly need it now but to
realize now the bureaucracy the
agreements they take in too much time
genocide in random happened because the
United Nations failed to send additional
additional forces there to stop the
violence is on the early stages that's
why the mechanism exists but how they
work how they work how they do work
there is the principle of right to
protect three stages the first stage
there is the sovereign country itself
sovereign country should protect their
own people first then sovereign country
should ask if it's necessary to have
external help either from the
international bodies or from
international community so and then
humanitarian intervention takes place
for example in Libya but if all these
interventions are good this is the
question what is going on in Libya today
it's a mess it's a mess that is why that
there are instruments but a lot of the
vacuum a lot of the gaps to bring to
bring assistance in time and to to bring
peace for durable period of
look what happened in Myanmar but the
problem existed ten years ago United
Nations interfered and then relations
stopped monitoring situation
reconciliation process failed even the
democratic government came to the power
so nothing happened
new old violence's are on the ground why
because the major problems they were not
resolved there so it's a complex
approach and how to use all these
instruments this is the question
peacekeepers are coming only where there
is peace to keep the United Nations does
not have mandate for peace enforcement
and this is the problem the skipping
peace building but only now so there are
debates how to bring this function to
one of the major instruments there are
many gaps we are to understand the
mechanism to to to better implement
existing instruments because during you
can't use one of the provisions of
Universal Declaration of Human Rights
violating other principle for example so
well-known debate freedom of expression
as I mentioned today French government
protected the you know these cartoons
magazines who who brought the image of
Muhammad in in the wrong way and it
created a big conflict so the French
government protected the the right to
freedom of expression millions of the
Muslims the event to the streets
demanding that their religious rights
were violated so it means
that in international relations in
domestic relations the golden rule
should prevail do not do to anybody what
you do not want to be undone towards you
don't do what you want to be done to
yourself so if you are enjoying one part
of the Euro rights human rights so and
violating the rights of others through
the freedom expression or not not a
right way of using this freedom of
expression so a lot of the things should
be well taken well well understood and
well implemented when we are trying to
to protect the universality of human
rights
please your questions
[Music]
well I think that this is a very
important point I mean what I was
referring to earlier when I talked about
the soft nature of the General Assembly
it is clearly so the General Assembly
its resolutions they don't have panting
attractions there they are not three two
applications you you cannot take a a
country before an international tribunal
for not living up to whatever norms have
been put in effect by the General
Assembly however the strength of the
General Assembly is exactly that it is
different from the Security Council it's
all of the Member States it's not only
15 it's not five of them that can stop
things with a veto so at the same time
it is about persuasion
it's not about
using brute force and when it comes to
persuasion and that they sort of what I
what I've been referring to all along
when we come to persuasion you have to
engage in persuasion and that's why I am
one of those that are skeptical about
the increase willingness to revert to
voting because when you revert to voting
you may be a little bit sort of
accepting that those that will be
against you they simply will continue to
be against you you have given up on
trying to convince people now convincing
people to do what you want them to do is
not an easy task you have to have a lot
of patience you cannot give up even
though it takes a very long time
but when we compare that to enforcement
under under Authority like the Security
Council has I think the case can be made
that it is not so simple to come to the
conclusion that enforcement of soft war
normative work necessarily means less
results we have endless examples of
enforcement with hard enforcement has
failed as well so I I think I simply
think of the camera just come to the
conclusion because we don't have
unfortunate we cannot effect any change
it is clear we have situations very
regrettable situations that will follow
us as humanity for a very long time like
the inaction in an errata but it is also
clear that today that there are many
there are many member states around the
world that were example belief and
decide that
the reason for the reluctance for many
things that are happening that the
international community that to heart in
its reactions to Libya at a time so it
cut all sways but and gates in in in
this conversation and and engaging in
trying to persuade someone it's actually
very important in international in
international work and they will look at
the world today I have sometimes heard a
cynical view I mean when when I was sent
over to New York I want dear friend of
mine in a very powerful position in
Iceland said to me when he actually
congratulated me on peeing on my way to
New York and I thanked him and said I
look very much forward to come and he
said really
in New York they argue over the same
text year after year decade after decade
and then they drop a word or at a comma
and type horse that I thought a little
bit about it and I said after a while
yes but how would the world look if
those diplomats over in New York had not
been doing that for the last 70 years
just think about it
the alternative might not be something
that is better it might actually be
something that is much worse and
regardless of the cynicism that we have
floating around we have numerous
evidence for a huge progress that has
been made on so many fields around the
world in the last 70 years so I don't
think that we should just to take that
out of the picture you should never give
up fighting the shortcomings but we
should all but we should also allow
ourselves to actually take some and try
to enjoy in what has what has been
achieved and there are quite a number of
things that have been achieved
your question is very important because
it's about the essence of the United
Nations generally so how the decisions
are being taken as ambassador said
things are slowly but they're changing
to the positive if for example Security
Council the main body who is adopting
the the sanctions and signing troops and
so on if for for decades
Security Council rejected any issues
which are not about the peace and
security including human rights human
rights violation is the basic for many
of the conflicts reasons but Security
Council rejected all these things only
recently we got recently and in few
decades the human rights of children in
armed conflict remaining in our conflict
the human rights becoming the one of the
important issues in the Security Council
so raising the awareness about the the
reasons of many conflicts so we are
trying to improve the existing system
there is no other system but what we
have so improvement of the system and
this is what exactly is being discussed
now including migration including
climate change I negotiated the bringing
the into the Security Council the the
problem of small island countries they
are disappearing they are losing
territories and people and Security
Council kept telling its climate change
is not to us good to the other bodies
and so on and then when they small other
countries they agreed to put the whole
order in different way so the challenge
to the safety peace and security for the
small owner carrie's because of the
climate change climate change in the end
not at the beginning so this my Security
Council
has this issue the problem of migrants
it was a very important resolution in
the Fed committee do you know that this
is the less protected part of the of the
population in the world because refugees
they are well protected by the
instruments migrants know all the
refugees are migrants not all the
boundaries are refugees so today if you
are speaking about Tuvalu Kira bath
Vanuatu
what to do if we can't stop the raising
of the ocean the only way to evacuate
them to evacuate you have to move to
give them them certain status not to be
stateless as you angel mentioned but do
you think that all the countries in the
region big countries they are so open to
host them no no look at the debates
which are going on so that's why the
debates in the third committee or on the
on the rights of migrants is very
important because we are to to succeed
with the declaration on migrants and
refugees adopted last year well to move
into implemented so somebody had a
question
please continue any questions yeah yes
what
I mean this is clearly a tea sector of
of our system today there is a very
strong focus on sovereignty of
individual countries we have seen of
course you know there are not so many
limitations on the sovereignty I mean
the most important one is of course the
security consonant the powers that the
Security Council has we have more sort
of willingness to revert to some kind of
international tribunals and and core
systems but still at the core of
everything is in the international
system is the independent sovereign
country and awhile we build upon that
building block we have to work with that
and of course that is reflected in most
of the work we are doing sir KF
mentioned the responsibility to protect
at the beginning know a little bit
earlier and to release responsibility to
protect the theory or doctrine came
about after what happened in in Rwanda
but if you if you read a little bit up
on on that doctrine you actually see
that they are very careful in saying
this does not constitute a tool to
override sovereignty it is rather seen
as a tool to encourage and support the
sovereign entities in doing what they
need to do
still today for example in the third
committee I think if we call back from
10-15 years there was a country specific
resolution Inter Committee on channel
meeting and it wouldn't surprise me that
it would be a part I think I think the
Chinese delicate almost said that he
hated country specifics or something to
that effect really reflecting their
experience with them
so I actually think the this brings
about you know also the question how how
do we deal with countries how are we
going to deal with them down the road we
are not going to dissolve them we are
not going to say it's like a company
that is cognate to bankruptcy and it is
called tocome to break it up and sell of
this part and that part and this is an
unviable company it is not so countries
are there and we need to continue to
work with it so what we do today has to
be done in such a manner that we can
still continue to work with them a
couple of years down the road so I think
it is important that we bear that in
mind
we need to be able even for those that
are temporarily sort of not very popular
with the rest of us we need to be able
to engage with them in such a manner
that we have a way a little bit further
down the road to engage with them in a
constructive manner and basically that
means that there are very strong
limitations on what we can do with a
country that does not want to cooperate
with the outer world and if we look at
the experiences where the rest of the
world goes in with placing cons trying
to overcome that such a situation it
might very well be argued that
experiences of that should not make us
to equal to do that because actually if
it just look at the reality it has not
worked out so well there is a long way
from corn and using military power over
to over to let's say peaceful state
building afterwards so if somebody is
contemplating of of of doing that they
should actually be trying to map out the
the whole way not just the first steps
basically any any moment any operation
United Nations is providing is based on
the invitation of the government so
United Nations can't come to do on its
own invitation should come the program
is that who is inviting if the
government itself is violator
so in Africa we had many of the facts on
that on one hand we have we have good
successes like Liberia discidium
cooperations then this building process
brought to good success a successful
story because the ownership is very
important that the civil society in the
country they took this ownership for
reconciliation and building sustainable
peace there all the factors should work
Myanmar is different so the they also
moved through the crisis the democratic
government was elected but
reconciliation process was not perfectly
finished and that's why the problem came
back came back and so we have thousands
of thousands of migrants
in protective of human rights several
factors should should work several
factors monitoring detecting raising the
awareness globally originally the role
of regional organizations are very
important so for me it is strange that
the the countries where democracy is
well recognized like Singapore like
Philippines lest most probably India
they're the neighbors why they are not
so well as to the human rights
violations in Myanmar their role as the
regional actors could could be
absolutely important there so the
protection of human rights this is not
the one instrument solution many many
factors should should work including
sanctions sanctions and photo
unfortunately they are coming when the
military conflict starts and the
bringing the the victims casualties look
at the severe so the first violations
were detected when three of all
protesters were killed but then dozens
of the killed then hundreds of them
killed thousands started to be killed
only only at that stage the Security
Council started to take making some
steps of course as it was said today
that the first responsibility to protect
their own people and their rights
belongs to the government to sovereign
government but it is not the case of the
government of Assad
so the interests of different global
players conflicted their Russia Iran
Saudi Arabia and the United States so
that's why the process was not so easy
to to launch and to to move ahead I
agree with the fact that sometimes we
ought to recognize more the the
differences tend to find the way how to
communicate the question is for example
Iran is Ana specific resolution being
criticized for different things for
tortures for punishments for and the
problem not all that the exercising the
capital punishment capital punishment is
being exercised in the United States and
many other countries how it is being
exercised they are bringing people
making them suffering because of
unacceptable unacceptable way of
punishment throwing the stones the soul
they are defending their tradition it's
our tradition we are telling them guys
we can recognize the can recognize the
cultural relativity but not moral
relativity no moral relativity when it
is about the human dignity and ways of
treating people so we have to understand
this this thing that that there are
limits when people can't can't be silent
yes okay you have your tradition but
what you are doing and this is about a
third committee who is bringing this
specific country resolution not to to
blame Iran for cultural diversity but to
demonstrate that what the ironic is not
the 21st century of behavior so this is
the these are the only mechanism United
Nations can can produce until the other
instruments
or the concept of instruments to be
implemented simultaneously well and I
mean let's just let's not forget that
actually this kind of work has had great
effect around the world it's not so that
all countries have had the same idea at
the same time I mean let's just take one
simple issue Kenter equality if you see
Kantar equality which we still have a
long way to go but we have seen a lot
happen in the last 100 years or so it
was not thought that this idea just
spread similar roles simultaneously in
all these places around the world it is
a classic example of of something that
has been passed on from country to
country through through civil society
Padma also by an axis by the
international community it is a classic
example that even though we have a lot
of shortcomings all around the world not
only in some countries that we think of
us being less progressive and it comes
to human rights than others and I want
to stress that all around the world my
countries has been ranked on the top on
the country called the in text know for
nine years in a row and it's fuming and
Iceland on the need to discussion on
social media not any less than in any
other country but I think it just shows
the power of persuasion you actually I
want people to recognize that it is
actually worth it even though it seems
to be a slow process drawn out and
sometimes you hit obstacles that may
make you a little bit cynical
and my only thing is to point out that
even though we have the shortcomings of
cold through these issues through parts
of a persuasion of words
it connects I actually actually a very
strong case can be made that this is a
very powerful way in the end even though
your luck the some of the elements of
sort of as someone who'd said
undiplomatic in the end diplomatically
beating someone to abeyance it is not
always about beating someone to obeyence
sometimes you have to persuade someone
to obey to to sort of falling in line or
or or seeing the sensibility of what you
are or what you are trying to sell them
yes finally
how drones or raps engineering
technology can basically change our
conception of what rights are and what
it was will be to intern or a shift in
the US
I don't think that this is an
undertaking that will ever be sort of
completed so in that sense you're
absolutely right as society evolves as
technology evolves we will we will have
new challenges for human rights and we
will probably have to evolve new
frontiers when it comes to the normative
sight of the world I and you have to
forgive me my ignorant again like I said
I did not read through all of the
documents that passed through my hands
this fall but I don't recall a sort of
off the cuff that we have seen a lot of
these issues in the third committee but
I remember some years back from work
taking place in the TA for example on
drones and and and artificial
intelligence in military action so even
in the third committee it was it is
about ethics it was about ethics in in
science and technologies and
particularly with artificial
intelligence
when is in the first committee
disarmament committee equation because
so sophisticated but under it being the
best on the earth artificial
intelligence created when the humankind
will not be able to control it to
control the processes so it should be in
agenda it should be an agenda of
different bodies of united nations and
of course as far as human human rights
it is about ethics it's about ethics
thank you so I guess that a glass of
wine is served outside thank you thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]